الى داخل مخيمات اللجوء يحمل الفلسطينيون
قضيتهم
كل شيء هنا يذكر بوطن غادروه الاعلام
واللافتات وصور من قتل في الداخل دفاعا عن
القضيه
لكن على خريطه لبنان ينقسم الفلسطينيون
فبينما يرى البعض ان الصواريخ التي اطلقت
من جنوبه تخفف الضغط عن فلسطينيين داخل
يؤكد اخرون ان ما يحدث لعبه سياسيه اقحمت
فيها القضيه اللي صار مسرحيه
مسرحيه واضحه ما بعرف كيف احكيها السياسي
بس واضحه انه جنوب مين بيفوت له غير اللي
حاكمينه واذا حدا يضرب من الفلسطينيه يعني
هاي صارت شماعه لفلسطينيه اذا بدهم من مين
ماشي فهي هاي صارت مسرحيه وواضحه لكل
الشعب العربي اللي موجود بلبنان ان كانوا
فلسطيني ولا مصري ولا لبناني التصويت
الجنوبيه لبنان تزامن مع زياره اسماعيل
هنيه الى بيروت هي المره الاولى التي يطلق
فيها هذا الكم من القذائف على دفعتين في
اليوم ذاته لتسقط في اماكن ماهوله ضربه لم
تغب عن اجتماع بين امين عام حزب الله
ورئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس الذين
تربطهما اكثر من ساحه بعيدا عن الاقصى كان
في عده غرض مستمره متصاعد وبهداف ايرانيه
بسوريا والحرس الثوري سارع واعلن عن مقتل
مستشارين عسكريا هذا الحرس الثوري اخذ
قرار الرد وبدنا نشير لموضوع الكلام
الاخير لامين العام لحزب الله لما طلع قال
انه اي استهدف اسرائيلي لاي مقيم على
الاراضي اللبنانيه حيحتم ردمن لبنان اي من
الحزب فهون كان عم يعطي الغطاء العسكري
والامني والسياسي لهذه العمليه زائد انه
كان في اجتماع مع رئيس مكتب السياسي لحركه
حماس اسماعيل هنيه مع قائد فيلا القدس
اسماعيل القهاني بالسفاره الايرانيه على
مائده الافطار قبل عشيه انطلاقه او اطلاق
الصواريخ وفيما
تسال الفلسطينيه لعلاقات بعيده عن كنف
الدوله تؤكد مصادر فتح انها ضد تحويل
فلسطين الى شماعه تعلق عليها سياسات دول
يعيش الفلسطينيون على امل العوده الى وطن
هجروا منه اما اللبنانيون فياملون
باستعاده سياده وطن تحول الى صندوق بريد
لرسائل اقليميه محفوفه بالمخاطر من مخيم
شاتيلا غنوه يتيم العربيه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات